[Musique]
c'est une question que je me pose
qu'est-ce qu'un navet en 25 ans de
cinéma agnès varda n'a pas souvent déçus
car toujours c'est l écoute du coeur
qu'elle nous a invités avec les hôtes 5
à 7 la pointe-courte le bonheur l'une
chante l'autre pas ou daguerréotype ce
centre documentaire sur les habitants de
son quartier
autant de films qu'on peut revoir
pendant un mois à l'épée de bois et tous
mes films repasse tous les jours
agnès varda 3 2e ici rue mouffetard j'ai
tourné en 1958 l'opéra moufter sorte
d'opéra la rue mouffetard c'était
surtout un parlementaire subjectif parce
que j'étais enceinte et j'ai été très
frappée par une émission de choses de
nourriture sais pas j'ai l'impression
que beaucoup mangé être enceinte fait
pareil moi qui pourtant la langue bien
pendue je ne vous dirai rien de l'opéra
bouffe qui est un film qui doit se voir
et s'écouter sur une très belle musique
de georges delerue
par ailleurs il descend parole
entre la pourriture et la vie
[Musique]
[Rires]
oui
[Musique]
j'habite au 6 rue daguerre où il ya un
marché magnifique mais j ai tourné un
film pas dans le marché alors dans le
côté de la rue plus calme on vient
justement des petits commerces enfin les
gens dont on parle moins souvent ce
qu'on ne voit pas justement dans ces
images pittoresques de paris et qui sont
de drôles de gens de drones de type type
s etc ce film que j'ai appelé d'agréger
rencontre janine
d'ailleurs pas c'est là où je
travaillais n'avaient souvent prendre
l'apéritif
enfin jacques ou maman tenait un café et
gdf et redire
et là j'ai rencontré mon mari j'étais
attiré par sa voix par sa gentillesse et
nous sommes sortis ensemble et ensuite
c'est venu tout seul
nous sommes sortis ensemble plusieurs
fois le théâtre de musique au le cinéma
mais jamais le bal notamment l' om balle
vers pasteur très mal famille et je me
suis aperçu que ses voisins étaient des
gens tout à fait intéressant
impressionnant et qu' ils s'étaient
rassemblés un jour de fête au café du
coin ici autour d'un illusionniste qui
s'appelait monsieur miss tags et qui
nous a tous mystifié de l'été la télé je
vais commenter mais ton avec eux croît
de 2,3 merci
[Musique]
hu à vous prononcer tout bas mot magique
le site e3 écoulée votre formule votre
magic
naturellement il reste plus ample et n'a
que 2 et croyez
mais ce coût devrait formuler trois
visites se transforme aussitôt en jeu
trois cadres fait je suis fait un pot
pourri de tous mes films c'est à dire
que j'ai fait comme on faisait dans les
brasseries canton jouer les meilleurs
airs d'un musicien j'ai mis bout-à-bout
de petits bouts de tous mes films courts
et longs j'ai pas si c'est très pourri
je sais pas si c'est un pot mais en tout
cas ça peut donner une idée de ce que je
fais à ceux qui ne veulent pas voir
plusieurs films et c'est un prise unique
ça ne coûtera que neuf
[Musique]